greetings my name is Josh Malaya and I'm
a senior marketing product manager at
Milton E biotech and today I'll be
talking about tumor processing for the
isolation and visualization of tumor
infiltrating leukocytes in today's
agenda will cover some background
information about Milton E biotech and
about tumor infiltrating leukocytes and
why they're so important
we'll then focus on the majority of the
talk which is still isolation for
improved downstream applications and
analyses there are seven different
sections starting with the importance of
sample preparation next we'll talk about
both manual and automated till isolation
using Mac's technology will then talk
about expanding tilt using cell culture
as well as the phenotypic analysis of
pills using flow cytometry and
single-cell sequencing and finally we'll
talk about the visualization of tumors
using light sheet microscopy will then
have a few concluding remarks and in
questions if time permits
a little bit about Milton a biotech
empowering discovery in advancing
therapy these words really do get to the
core mission of this company and that is
to improve scientific understanding and
medical progress by providing solutions
that advance biomedical research and
cellular therapies and we achieve this
by our ongoing commitment to providing
newer and smarter technologies to the
scientists and clinicians that are
paving the way for longer and healthier
lives
and as a company we were able to do this
with 30 years of experience in nearly
3,000 employees 20% of which are in
research and development which is well
above industry standards our product
have been published in more than 20,000
papers and we have nearly 20,000
products but I think the most impressive
number on this slide are the more than
55,000 cellular therapy procedures that
have been carried out using our
technology in more than 2,500 patients
that have been treated with cellular
therapies using our platforms
so next
we'll move on to Milton a biotech and
talk about tools and why are we talking
about tools and why are they so
important I think to adequately address
this we have to talk about the
uncomfortable topic of death so the
history of death as told by humans so in
order to do this we have to take a step
back step way back about thirty thousand
years to one of our more latest common
ancestors who live to be about thirty
years of age and would die from a
variety of reasons including falling
from roxxor succumbing to injuries from
hunting starvation disease predation and
over the next twenty nine thousand nine
hundred years we only gained about ten
years but in the past 125 years we've
more than doubled our life expectancy
now this occurred around the turn of the
20th century we can largely be
attributed to accessibility to
antibiotics worldwide vaccination
campaigns and advancements in water
purification technologies now despite
all of these advancements we still die
but how we die has changed if you look
at the United States and 1900 at the
turn of the 20th century 53 percent of
people would succumb to infectious
disease
fast forward 110 years that number
dropped at 3 percent
now that void was filled by cardio
disease and cancer with cancer
increasing by more than 500 percent in
that time period and as you can clearly
see in 2016 and 2017 cancer was the
second leading cause of death in the
United States and when we look at the
types of cancers that are causing the
death a vast majority over 90 percent
are solid tumors and this is directly
applicable to the topic we're talking
about today with tumor infiltrating
leukocytes now when someone's diagnosed
with cancer there are various treatment
options available
these include surgery chemotherapy and
radiation therapy they have significant
side effects there are therapies that
target specific mutations and tumors but
in the last decade
much of the focus
on immunotherapies now there are a lot
of different amino therapies that are
connected with a lot of different immune
cells there are T and NK cell therapies
there are cancer vaccines checkpoint
inhibitors checkpoint modulators uncle
it expires all of which affects both the
adaptive and innate immune systems and
it can actually their effects can be
quite broad in effect this next slide
kind of shows with the traditional
standard of care on the left and amino
therapies on the right you can see that
all these different arrows show the
plant tropic effects of these different
therapies and the purpose of this slide
is is not to explain everything but to
highlight that a vast majority of these
impact the tumor microenvironment in the
tumor infiltrating leukocytes that
reside within now two more tumor
infiltrating leukocytes are comprised of
a lot of different white blood cells you
have dendritic cells t-cells both cd4
and cd8 you have T regulatory cells
macrophages and K cells and other
subtypes and all of these cells can have
both Pro and anti tumorigenic properties
now one of the featured applications of
therapeutic applications of tills
came out last year where a patient that
had metastatic breast cancer had tools
isolated from her tumor these were
screened against a panel of neo epitopes
reactive cd4 and cd8 cells of interest
were then expanded in vitro were
reintroduced into this patient as she
underwent a complete and durable
regression for a two-year period now
this is very exciting and shows the
therapeutic potential of these cells and
this is seen and the clinical trial in
the clinical trial field where you have
more than 500 occurring right now a
majority of these are within the United
States and within Europe but there's
also an increasing number in China and
Asia Asia Pacific so moving on to our
till workflow so we start with our solid
tissue in this case it being it's a
tumor we then moved to sample
preparation followed by cell separation
to isolate your cell type of interest
and follow that with various downstream
applications
these can include cell culture and cell
analysis single-cell sequencing but
we've also added a new workflow and this
allows you to take 3d images of whole
tumors utilizing light sheet microscopy
so we'll start with the importance of
sample preparation
so we start with a solid tumor solid
tumor is comprised at the mixture of
cells extracellular matrices basal
membranes vasculature necrotic tissue
fat and while it's ideal to process a
tissue or a tumor immediately sometimes
that's not possible if it needs to be
shipped to another lab or if it arrives
late at night fortunately we have a
solution a tissue storage solution and
this allows you to keep yourselves for
up to 48 hours and maintain cell
viability and functionality this graph
here is showing after 48 hours till x'
recovered from a tumor after being
stored either at 4 degrees or at room
temperature compared to two of the
competitors or a fresh tumor where
obviously you're going to lose all of
your cells after 48 hours so whether
you're starting with fresh tumor tissue
or tumor tissue that has been stored for
48 hours or less in our tissue storage
solution the first goal of your tissue
dissociation should be to reproducibly
dissociate the tumor into a single cell
suspension now the basic approach to
this would be mechanical disruption this
is missing and chopping straining
mashing combined with enzymatic
digestion and at the end of the day it's
not much different than preparation of
food now the second goal should be
preservation of surface epitopes now
this is important for accuracy no typing
and downstream functional assays and you
have a lot of different choices when it
comes to enzymes there come from
different sources
they have different targets and they
have different strengths what happens
when you are using a variety of
different enzymes is you can have a low
yield with high viability which means
you probably under digested you should
increase the concentration or perhaps
switch to a stronger enzyme conversely
if you have a high yield and low
viability the digestion has been too
strong you should either decrease the
concentration or maybe reduce the
incubation time now the problem with
this is making these adjustments
consumes time and resources and it's
only applicable to that specific batch
of enzyme from that specific vendor
there's a huge amount of variability
when it comes to
the type the quality and nomenclature of
the enzymes that are out there
fortunately we have come up with a tumor
dissociation kit that has quality
assured lot consistent enzymatic
activities for reproducibility we've
optimally titrated these for increased
yields and higher viability of cells and
we make sure to have the preservation of
surface epitopes and both human and
mouse pills
so the third goal should be to maintain
cell viability and functionality and
this is something that I'll talk about
in more detail in the next section
to the gentle max so we've talked about
mechanical disruption and enzymatic
digestion and it's really important to
have a balance between the two in to
that extent we have developed the gentle
max it is a highly reliable and user
independent tissue dissociate er
next I'll show you a brief video of what
it looks like to dissociate a mouse
tumor using the gentle Maxx octo with
heaters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay now that we've seen how easy and
user independent tumor dissociation is
into a single cell suspension using the
gentle max octet with heaters I want to
talk a little bit about the importance
of the tissue dissociation kit itself
and one way to really show this is to
use the tissue dissociation kit when
digesting the tumor and seeing what
populations that you get so if you don't
use the kit it's a lot harder to find
any of the Tim three positive pd-1
positive or lagg-3 positive pd-1
positive cells of interest but when we
utilize our tissue dissociation kit you
can readily see those populations become
visible and here's the difference in
those percentages a lot of times the
cells of interests are right at the
interface of the tumor and standard
dissociation techniques are not capable
of getting those cells separated and
allowing you to analyze those so we've
developed an epitope preservation list
for both human and mouse we look at the
sensitivity of these different epitopes
to our tissue dissociation kits and to
see if they're stable moderately
sensitive or strongly sensitive and if
your epitope of interest is strongly
sensitive or moderately sensitive to our
tumor dissociation kits you can preserve
100% of the epitopes by reducing enzyme
our
now aside from being able to accurately
phenotype these cells epitopes are
important also for functionality so we
took a look at two different patients we
isolated T cells from two different
patients and Cohen created them with
autologous tumor cells and you can see
that when comparing overnight digestion
versus died dissociation using the
gentle max that both patients were able
to produce significantly more interferon
gamma when Co cultured with their
otologist tumors
in summary with the gentle max we asked
you to start smart we have our gentle
max dissociate err we have our tissue
dissociation kits as well as our gentle
max tubes strainers and filters as well
as our tissue storage solution to have
your simple preparation start off right
now that we have our single cell
suspension we can now isolate our tools
using max technology now max technology
is comprised of three main components
the first being our micro beads these
micro beads are small about 50
nanometers inside science they're made
of iron oxide that are conjugated to
antibodies that are specific for the
cells of interest when combined with our
max columns which are really the heart
of the technology that allowed the
magnetic field to be increased by 10,000
fold when placed inside of our
separators the combination of these
three allow for minimal labeling
excellent curing excellent recovery and
high specificity
now this video shows the principle on
action this video demonstrates what is
taking place inside the column with both
the target and non target cells flowing
freely through the steel ball matrix
when outside of the magnetic separator
the target cells have been minimally
labeled with our microbeads and once the
column is placed inside the separator
the highly amplified magnetic forces
cause the target cells to hover and
suspension while the non target cells
continue to flow freely through the
column note that the cells are being
held in suspension and are not pressed
up against the steel ball matrix once
the column is removed from the separator
the paramagnetic microbeads no longer
have the attraction to the steel ball
matrix in your purified eTools
flow freely out of the column and into
what undoubtedly will be a wildly
successful experiment so that video
showed you the basic principle of Mac's
technology now when we look at the
different types of t-cell subsets that
can be isolated using our until
microbeads we have our cd4 microbeads we
have our cd8 microbeads as well as our
cd4 and cd8 microbeads if you're
interested in both populations but how
do we actually get these cells and what
does that look like on the next slide
I'll show you a video of what it looks
like to isolate pills using Mac's
technology
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so now that we've seen how easy it is to
isolate ills using max technology I want
to talk about one of the primary
benefits and that's the time that's
saved the time that's saved when you're
doing your phenotypic analysis at a flow
cytometer if you look at the amount of
time that it takes to analyze 8 to 10
samples of isolated or bulk samples you
can see the amount of time saved is
dramatic losses as I mentioned only
eight or nine samples but what if you're
processing lots of samples this is where
cell separation meets German automation
we have our manual separation you can
increase that in the manual method by
using an auto that has eight separators
if you want a fully automated system we
have the Auto maxpro separator that
allows you to isolate up to six samples
at a time and it's completely automated
if you're interested in a little bit
more throughput we have our multi-max
cell 24 separator Plus this is a semi
automated instrument that allows you to
separate up to 24 samples at a time and
the combination of the two we have the
multi-max X which is a fully automated
high throughput instrument that allows
for the isolation fully automated of up
to 24 tool samples at a time and if we
look at the relative performance of the
isolation methods that we talked about
you can see that manual separation the
multi-max 24 and the multi-max x have
comparable performance when it comes to
purity and yield now another method when
people are looking to isolate cells of
interest is cell sorting in to that
extent we have the max quant Taito is a
gentle cell sorting system and with a
closed cartridge that has no sheet fluid
it's engineered for operator safety with
no aerosols or droplet formation and it
has intuitive handling suitable for any
lab professional
and this next video will show you how
the cartridge really is the heart of the
title the max quant title cartridge
represents the heart of the max quant
title sorter it is a fully closed system
containing three chambers an input
chamber a positive sword chamber where
target cells are collected and a
negative sort chamber where non selected
cells remain after each sort note
sorting happens exclusively in the
cartridge there are no fluidics within
the instrument itself all three chambers
can be accessed from above through luer
lock ports which allow for easy loading
of the sample after loading the sample
into the input chamber the cartridge is
placed inside the instrument at the
beginning of the sword process pre
filtered air coming from the instrument
enters through a 0.1 micrometer filter
at the bottom of the cartridge the air
then moves through an air channel and
finally enters the input chamber through
another 0.1 micrometer filter the very
mild air pressure drives the cell
suspension through a microfluidic
channel onto the microchip where the
selected target cells are then sorted
into positive and negative fractions
after entering the micro channel cells
are interrogated by three lasers upon
identification of a target cell a
magnetic pulse opens the micro valve
which then redirects the target cell
into the positive collection chamber the
whole sorting procedure happens at a
very low pressure of only 3 psi and
there is no decompression or charge
applied to the cells after the sort has
been completed the max quant title
cartridge is taken out of the instrument
and the sample can be retrieved under a
sterile hood for further processing as
you can see sorting within the closed
and sterile environment of the max quant
title cartridge is much gentler and
easier than on a conventional droplet
sorter
max quantizer fast and easy gentle to
cells fully Stara and completely safe
visit us at Milton e biotech comm /title
Milton e biotech
[Music]
now that we've isolated our tools of
interest using either Mac's technology
or the Mac's quantize oh these cells are
now suitable for downstream applications
the first of which that we're going to
talk about is cell culture now if you
have an interest in expanding your tools
there are obviously a lot of different
components that are necessary for this
the first of which is medium
we recommend using lineage-specific
media to which we have both T cell and
NK cell media our T cell media is called
text max it's been optimized for cell
culture developed for high performance
cultivation and both human and mouse
t-cells you'll be able to get optimal
growth high expansion rates and reliable
activation and this has been designed to
function without serum our NK medium has
been optimized for the expansion of
human and K cells you'll see superior NK
expansion using this product it's a Zeno
free and it's been designed to result in
minimal growth of unwanted cells
especially T cells now in addition to
media you're going to need cytokines we
have both human and mouse from research
premium grade to GMT but one of the
things that's important to talk about
with cytokine usage is a lot specific
activity in this next video you'll see
why it is so important to know the lot
specific activity of the cytokines that
you're using in your experiment each lot
of a standard cytokine has a dedicated
biological activity this means although
you always add the same amount of
cytokine in nanograms to your cell
culture experiments you might end up
adding different amounts of active
cytokine the cytokine activity affects
the response you measure while low unit
concentrations lead to low response
rates a small increase of units per
milliliter can cause a huge jump in the
response
finally the response curve hits a
plateau relying on nanogram amounts you
never really know how much active
cytokine you're adding to be sure to
achieve maximal response rates huge
nanogram amounts are added as a result
cells are often oversaturated and very
artificial cell culture conditions are
created
but did you know that there is a way to
check the precise cytokine activity with
Max premium-grade cytokines you know the
lot specific cytokine activity because
we already did the testing for you
relying on this information you can
always add the same amount of active
cytokine to your experiment you can rule
out any kind of variability moving a
huge step closer to reproducible cell
culture results plus you don't need to
over saturate your experiment anymore
this also means that you can use up to
ten times less reagent choose lot
specific cytokine activity with max
premium-grade cytokines to save time
increase reproducibility and reduce
costs
[Music]
now that we've seen the importance of
lot specific activity when adding
cytokines to your cell culture if you're
going to be expanding t-cells you'll
need to activate them to that extent we
have developed t-cell transact for human
t-cells now this product uses volumetric
dosing which means you don't have to
count yourselves for accurate beep to
cell ratios it's ready to use you don't
have to mix for a minute prior to usage
you can remove it by a simple wash you
don't have to go through a D beating
step that's going to result in
significant loss of yourself we have a
robust simulation we have highest cell
viability and we have this product
available up to GMP and this is
important for researchers that are
looking to translate their studies
as mentioned the GMP availability of
transact that is not restricted only to
that but also we have that for our media
and cytokines and so our cell culture
portfolio really is primed for
individuals that are looking to
translate their research aside from just
the products we also have a platform
that allows you to expand cells and this
is the clinton max prodigy the clinton
max prodigy allows for the expansion of
tools in a functionally closed and
automated system next we'll show a brief
video highlighting some of the
capabilities and features of this
platform
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
so as you can see we not only have the
reagents but we also have the
instrumentation for the expansion of
tools in vitro this next section is
entitled cell analysis reassess your
antibodies and the reason we're talking
about this has to do with
reproducibility in the role that
antibodies have played in the lack
thereof now standard hybrid OVA
antibodies have a lot of problems that
are associated with them you can get
spontaneous light chains that pop up you
can get mutations over time and to that
extent we came up with our own
antibodies now these are recombinant Lee
generated these are made to meet new
reproducibility standards we utilize one
universal isotype that's human IgG one
this is made to reduce complexity the
experiment planning and we've also
mutated the FC region this is especially
important when talking about to analysis
as this is made to eliminate background
signal to highlight the importance of
this FC mutation we have two different
samples we have splenocytes and tumor
cells with or without FC are blocking
comparing our real Finity antibodies to
typical hybridoma antibodies and you can
see in splenocytes without SVR blocking
where there isn't a lot of SPR
expression the difference between the
two is not much when you add SCR
blocking the again are very similar but
when you look at tumor cells the
background and because he's expressed
such high levels of SAR you can see
using traditional hybridoma antibodies
that you're not able to distinguish
tumor cells from non tumor cells even
with FC are blocking the background is
much higher than that of RIA Finity so
Rio Finity doesn't not just replace SCR
blocking it's better than actually are
blocking to this extent we've come up
with an application node recently that
talked about the background free
analysis of tools and the primary
takeaway point is that if you're not
blocking the FCR receptor adequately you
can grossly overestimate the number of
tools and the populations that are
represented amongst them so for accurate
phenotypic analysis it's critically
important to have FC blocking or more
separably have a mutated SC region that
allows for minimal background staining
we've come up with a couple of different
panels for till phenotypic analysis all
of these are using our RIA antibodies
and now that you've stained your
enriched tools for bit with the above
panels it's time to go to the flow
cytometry
introduction to the max Quandt family of
flow cytometry we have a variety of
different Saitama ters for different
needs we have the max Quan vibe that
utilizes a yellow laser for fluorescent
proteins we have the max quant 10 we
have the max 116 for more parameters if
that's what's necessary and we also have
the max quantex for high throughput
analysis
so now that we talked about cell culture
and cell analysis we're going to talk
about single-cell sequencing
we've had a relatively recent
collaborative development with 10x
genomics and this came about when you
look at the pie graph below you can see
that a vast majority of the technical
supports question that 10x was fielding
from their customers had to do with
sample prep in their workflow so we've
looked at three primary ways to clean up
the sample prep we looked at debris
removal red blood cell lysis and dead
cell removal and we compared the results
and how that improved the readout of
single cell sequencing as mentioned we
have our RBC lysis that allows you to
lifes the blood cells of interest we
have our debris removal that will get
rid of a lot of the background signal
and then we have our dead cell removal
these cells produce toxic compounds and
can impact now stream applications
they're also very sticky which makes
single cell sequencing very difficult so
the basic study design is we looked at a
breast tumor model the 41 model we
looked at tumors we'd associated them
Illustrated them they underwent RBC
lysis and then one or two rounds of dead
cell removal we looked at nine different
tumors from three different tissues into
three different repetitions and we
looked at over eighty four thousand
single cells the goals of those study
were to look at the performance the
reproducibility in the tumor
heterogeneity so first when we look at
either post filtration with debris
removal if we look at post RBC lysis B
or C or D which are post dead cell
removals once or twice you can see that
library cleanliness goes up as well as
the library complexity
when you look at reproducibility of
filtered only versus samples that have
RBC and dead cell removal you can see
that the reproducibility is better as
well as the the signal of the cell and
lastly we looked at the heterogeneity
that one is able to get from these
samples and you can see that by removing
RBC's and removing the dead cells that
you get a much clearer picture of what's
going on within the tumor
so these are our primary applications
that we focus on the recently we have
another layer and this has to do with 3d
imaging using whole tissues so there's a
two-step protocol that will ultimately
allow you to take 3d pictures of tissues
within
so on this next section we'll talk about
visualizing tools with the ultra
microscope now the ultra microscope is
flexible and easy
it's an optimized light sheet microscope
we provide you with all the clearing
protocols necessary and this allows you
to interrogate and take 3d pictures of
large samples the basic process is the
first you first need to immuno stain
your tissue of interest and you can do
this with one of our 14 thousand
different Rio Finiti antibodies the
second step is tissue clearing that
allows you to remove both fat and
liquids that cause diffraction of the
light and we can see here is the result
when we look at a pancreatic tumor
targeted with car T cells this video
shows a xenograft of a human pancreatic
carcinoma cell line which expresses GFP
along with infiltrating car T cells
shown in violent sample preparation
involved hole mount immuno labeling
followed by ethyl cinema clearing the 3d
data of the tumor were created using the
ultra microscope to lightsheet
microscope the car T cells are labeled
using Rhea 8:44 clones conjugated with
bio 667 detecting human cd2 71 with
vasculature being seen in orange
you
this video shows you the power of the
ultra microscope and how it allows you
to visualize tools where they are within
the tumor micro-environment something
that's simply not possible with other
workflows so in summary we've gone
through all the different steps of the
two different workflows whether it's for
imaging or for sample preparation cell
separation for cell culture phenotypic
analysis or single cell sequencing now
there's been a lot of information to
digest but this is really because we
have such an extensive and comprehensive
workflow for the till for tilt
researchers
our eyes with a few key takeaway points
from each section first with sample
preparation we talked about the
advantages of the gentle max and the
tumor dissociation kids primarily that
it's user independent it's fully
automated and it improves yield
viability and reproducibility by using
this episode by using this you preserve
epitopes necessary for accurate
phenotypic analysis as well as
functional analyses next we talk about
the isolation of tools using max
technology this allows for improved
phenotypic resolution and accuracy while
reducing the need for the time needed
for phenotypic analysis next we talk
about culturing tools for both basic and
translational research the importance of
lineage specific media lot specific
activity when utilizing cytokines and
the advantages of T cell transact so
next we talked about the analysis of
tools using our next generation of
antibodies these are areas these are
recombinant ly generated antibodies that
use a universal isotype that being human
I eat one and a mutated FC region that
greatly reduces background signal
and then finally we talked about the
visualization of tills and the clear
advantage of the ultra microscope -
which allows you to visualize where
these tools are within the tumor
microenvironment something that simply
is not possible otherwise so with that I
appreciate your time and interest and
please let me know if you have any
questions all resources will be
available at the booth and thank you for
your attention